I took your advice.
It was very good advice.
Sean? Sean?
Look, I can see that you think you know me but I don't know who you are.
My name is Captain Colter Stevens.
You're kind of freaking me out.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Talk to me, Sean.
Look, I don't know who Sean is and I don't know who you are.
Welcome back Captain Stevens.
Where am I?
You are inside the Source Code.
What is the Source Code?
It's a computer program, Captain.
Source Code enables you to cross over into another man's identity in the last eight minutes of his life.
At 7:48 this morning, a bomb exploded on a train outside of Chicago killing everyone on board.
A man named Sean Fentress was on that train.
He is now you.
Think Captain, remember back.
Who bombed the train?
I don't know who bombed the train!
Then try again.
Wait, no.
So, what do you think?
It's the same train but it's different.
We've been informed there'll be another attack in six hours.
If you find the bomber, the next attack can be prevented.
Concentrate on the passengers in your car.
Look for ones who seem nervous.
As always you will have eight minutes.
Eight minutes, and then I blow up again.
What would you do if you knew you had less than eight minutes to live?
I'd make those seconds count.
I wanna go back in.
I'm gonna save her.
You can't, it doesn't work that way.
Christina is dead.
She doesn't have to be.
You cannot alter this reality while inside the Source Code.
I'm asking you to have the decency to let me try.
What's going on?
He's in trouble.
Tell me everything's gonna be okay.
Everything's gonna be okay.